welcome to bananamores i can't even
contain my excitement for this next
comedian
all you people watching at home get
those hands of clapping
hi thank you so much for having me my
name is sam morrison i live in new york
city but
i don't like it because it's gross only
city where like water falls on you and
you're like oh god
oh no that could be anything
oh oh good it's just tears that's
i gave money to a homeless man and my
friend
was you know real new yorkers don't give
money to the homeless
i was like real new yorkers are homeless
you think you're more new yorker than j
train bagel tony
his best friend's a bagel like you can't
win
i was walking down the street with my
boyfriend one time this guy told us to
go back to where we come from
which is weird because we're white and
gay this guy
thinks there's a country
like i guess where gay people come from
which means he knows about canada
that's our secret okay you and i
i think my favorite part about being gay
is that um
i don't have to follow the rules like
there's a lot of rules you gotta follow
when you're a man when you're like a
straight man you got to be manly you got
not me i'm free i can do this
look at me i can wear earrings
men can't wear earrings but they can
wear watches because time is straight
but sound is gay
it's like who made these rules you can't
wear shorts that are too short those are
gay
long shorts those are cool but capris
are gay pants are straight pants suits
are lesbian
and theater is gay but if you're in your
underwear it's wrestling
who's got time to memorize these 300
years ago they were
opposite like men were heels and wigs
and makeup
heels wigs makeup i'm sorry if george
washington were here today
ross matthews would take one look at him
like we need that queen on drag
race legs for days beat to the gods
sure she doesn't have teeth but honey
she has charisma
they'd have a whole season of course i'd
be called founding daddies
guys that's me i'm sam morrison thank
you so much for having me and keep it
going for mitzi
i can't even get over how much talent
this person has the banana more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya
i'm so excited to watch this next
performer light up
the banana more stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you mitzi my my kindred spirits
ah i'm struggling because i'm single in
a pandemic and it doesn't help that i
have
trust issues you know but i'm finally
starting to let my guard down
and this really cute guy dm'd me on
instagram
and we're chatting we're hitting it off
and he's perfect like he eats every part
of the chicken and he respects michelle
branch you know those are two things i
look for in a soulmate
and we're talking for maybe three weeks
four weeks
and this is all still on instagram no
phone numbers so one night i'm filming
frisky
and i say let's facetime i'm nervous
because we've never had face-to-face
interaction
and i'm waiting for him to reply he's
typing and he says
i'd love to facetime but i can't
i have an android
[Laughter]
my heart dropped is if he just told me
he has a wife
like why would you keep this from me
and i feel like this is something you
should have mentioned up front
were you hiding it did you think i
wasn't gonna find out
i'm sorry but iphone and androids that's
a historical feud that is like
jlo and mariah carey you know i'm upset
i've been bamboozled
as much as i i like this guy i just
can't picture myself in a relationship
without airdrop you know like
can you imagine how am i gonna start
a group chat with you and my family you
see how there's no future here
how which way are we going to raise our
kids like
they'll grow up so confused like if he
goes missing i can't find his location
you know it's just bye-bye
i can i can maybe handle a guy who
you know uh doesn't like dogs a guy who
thinks the earth is flat but that green
bubble
is a deal breaker unfortunately
of course all my friends are getting
married and
their their weddings got postponed
because the pandemic so now i'm i'm
gonna be a bridesmaid like four
times in september it's just one more
and i get a free boba milk tea
stamp card system and i i hate it
i hate it so much i know a lot of girls
love it but i hate it
like at this point i don't know what's
worse getting asked to be a bridesmaid
or getting selected for jury duty
just the same dread same burden
when i open up that envelope
why me you know i wish i could get out
of being a bridesmaid like i can get out
of jury duty
like i wish i could just go to the
wedding and pretend i don't know english
just call up the bride and tell her that
i hate cops like how do i get out of
this
and just like jury duty you're just
forced to interact with people you don't
know
like the bachelorette weekend is a
nightmare and everyone's on their phones
with the instagram going live just
cameras in every direction like what
reality show that i sign up for it's me
the college roommate the cousin the the
groom's
sister the the summer camp bff the
the hair stylist the the college
roommate like it's literally seven
strangers
picked to live in a house and have their
lives taped
count me out all right y'all i'm sherry
cola
back to you mitzi there's no place
like fun can you believe you get to
watch comedy that good right
from your home this next comic is
responsible for most of my wrinkles
caused by all the laugh lines
you think i was on the floor
[Applause]
hey guys so what is going on
oh my god hey look give it up for mitsy
woo thank you without her this would not
be possible
you're looking good dudes we go way back
all right front row really showed up
tonight you guys are looking fancy
you're like i'll use any excuse to dress
up
it is so good to be here though no lie
i've been fiending for human activity
honest to god and by here i do mean my
childhood home
that's not an exaggeration back living
with the rents
what it is what it do yeah i'm 26.
i'm 26. and my friends are all getting
back out into the dating world
seriously i mean i don't know if i'm
ready for it just because i'm kind of
comfortable to be honest
and dating was already hard right before
all this happened
now i mean add on all the other extra
pressures you got to think about
right i won't even get into it because
you already know there's just so much to
think about
okay and in my friend group i am
the designated detective okay anytime
one of my friends
has a prospective suitor i'm gonna look
him up right i'm good at that i was a
former cia agent in my previous life
that's self-diagnosed i have no idea but
regardless i'm finding out the facts
i am and there's certain places that i'm
gonna go
to look up these facts right my friends
are like how are you gonna find the
information
is it legal yeah cindy it's legal
okay no i'm not going to facebook though
you know what i'm going to find there
pictures from their 5th grade laser tag
birthday
snoozefest that's not going to give me
anything no
no you're laughing because you had a
laser tag birthday that's embarrassing
i did too though i did too that party
was lit i'm not gonna lie
i had so much fun at laser tag oh my god
i sweat bullets though
anyway oh my god
linkedin that's another one that place
is a wasteland you're not gonna find
anything interesting there a bunch of
articles that they reposted
yeah useless right the top trends of
business
in 2013. they didn't care about that
nope
[Laughter]
that's why the only place to get a full
background check
is where venmo
kids yes it is
right this guy's sweating over here
because he's like
i didn't know people could track then
they can and we do
okay you know why because venmo is
honestly a bank statement for most
people all the transactions are there
right you can tell if they paid their
rent late
yep you can tell what sketchy stuff they
did
at 3am on march 30th
you can if they use an excessive amount
of certain emojis
like the purple animated crab emoji what
even is that emoji
i told my friend i was like no you can't
date him she's like okay that's a little
harsh i was like fine go enjoy
a dollar fry from mcdonald's okay
that's right they're petty they're not
gonna forget anything that you did wrong
uh you guys have been great you guys are
so
cute sexy saucy i loved it thank you
guys that's my time tonight
mitzi back over to you let's walk thanks
guys
i literally am gonna send that set to
all my friends right now